♪ ♪
>> Dana: LAST WEEK, JESSE AND
I HAD THE HONOR OF ATTENDING THE
WAITING FOR WISHES DINNER
NASHVILLE TO HELP RAISE MONEY
FOR FRUIT SOME VERY SPECIAL
CHARITIES.
WE WAITED THE TABLES AND IT WAS
AN AMAZING NIGHT.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THIS YET.
>> LET'S WELCOME DANA PERINO.
JESSE WATTERS.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW HOW
JESSE WATTERS GOT INVITED.
YOU WANT TO TELL US ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT?
>> IT WAS A COMPLETE SURPRISE TO
ME TOO.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> Dana: THIS IS MY WORLD!
HE'S LIKE MY KID BROTHER.
I HAVE TO TAKE HIM ALONG
EVERYWHERE.
I DID WAIT TABLES YEARS AGO.
WE WILL FIGURE THIS OUT.
I AM NOT EVEN SURE WHAT I AM
DOING.
WE WILL MAKE IT WORK.
>> Jesse: I NEED BROWN BREAD.
SOMEONE NEEDS BROWN BREAD.
>> Dana: JESSE, ARE YOU
WORKING?
ARE YOU HARDLY WORKING?
>> Jesse: I NEED BROWN BREAD
FOR A TABLE.
WHERE DO I GET THAT?
CAN I BUTTER YOUR ROLL
CAN I BUTTER YOUR ROLL?
DO YOU LIKE A LOT OF BUTTER OR A
LITTLE BUTTER?
SLATHER IT ON?
LET ME SIGN SOMETHING.
YOU PROBABLY JUST WANT THE NFL
PLAYERS TO RUIN IT.
>> Dana: HOW MUCH IS JASPER
WORTH?
>> Jesse: YOU BETTER BE
PUTTING MONEY IN FOR ME.
TAKE TIME FOR EVERYBODY.
I AM GOING TO DIG IN.
>> Jesse: GO AHEAD.
MEDIUM RARE?
IS THAT GOOD?
>> Dana: THIS IS DAILY.
MAKE HIM FAMOUS.
>> Jesse: I LIKE THE POCKET
SQUARE.
IT'S SHARP.
CAN I GIVE YOU A SECRET?
DRESS FOR THE JOB YOU WANT, NOT
THE JOB YOU HAVE.
>> Dana: I'VE GOT TO DO A
PLAYBACK.
ARE YOU EATING THAT?
>> Jesse: THIS IS NOT MY
PLACE.
I JUST SAT DOWN.
>> WE HAVE JESSE WATTERS AND
DANA PERINO.
>> Dana: THAT MADE US LOOK
LIKE WE WERE THE ONLY
CELEBRITIES THERE.
IT'S MUSIC THERE WERE A LOT
BIGGER CELEBRITIES.
>> Dana: MUCH BIGGER
CELEBRITIES.
>> Greg: YOU ARE A GOOD
WAITRESS.
YOU HAD PLATES GOING UP YOUR
ARM.
>> Dana: THAT'S HOW I GOT
THROUGH COLLEGE.
IT WAS A REALLY WONDERFUL EVENT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT MEETING
KEVIN CARTER?
>> Jesse: HE WAS GREAT.
THE YOUNG MAN WHO I GIVE A TIP
ABOUT THE POCKET SQUARE.
HE WAS AN AMBASSADOR.
WE RAISED A LOT OF MONEY FOR THE
MAKE-A-WISH FOUNDATION.
IT WAS WORTHWHILE.
MAYBE KIMBERLY CAN COME NEXT
YEAR AND WAIT SOME TABLES AS
WELL.
JUAN I'M NOT SO SURE.
GREG IS PROBABLY BUSY.
>> Kimberly: I AM VERY GOOD AT
DISHES TOO.
>> Dana: THEY NEEDED
BARTENDERS.
>> Greg: I WOULD BE A GREAT
BARTENDER.
>> Jesse: CHRIS COLLINSWORTH
BARTENDED THE ENTIRE THING.
I THINK THAT WAS HIS WAY OF
GETTING OUT OF WAITING TABLES.
>> Dana: TITO ORTIZ WAS THERE.
>> Jesse: HE SAID IF YOU'RE
EVER IN A FIGHT, PUNCH THEM IN
THE NOSE.
>> Kimberly: BECAUSE IT STUNS
THEM.
>> Greg: HE CAN PUNCH.
AND YOU...
>> Jesse: I CAN TAKE A PUNCH.
I HAVE A BIG CHAIN.
>> Dana: I'VE NEVER BEEN TO AN
EVENT LIKE THAT.
THE PATRONS PAY TO COME TO THE
DINNER AND THEN THERE'S THE LIVE
AUCTION.